[Musique]
voyez on l'entend
l'inauguration des gones en 6ème édition
c'est parti le bolloc'h - wass de samui
de s'amuser et aussi regarder un film et
aussi bien dormir tu vas trouver tout ça
aux gens venez temps
[Musique]
oui s'il a été réalisé par les agents du
conseil départemental depuis le mois
d'août on s'active on travaille jour et
nuit
on ferme parfois liés à nous étions
encore là jusqu'à minuit pour terminer
tout ça pour que tout ça soit réussie en
beauté l'amour c'est quelque chose de
gratuit et le bonheur c'est aussi
quelque chose de gratuit pour ça que
nous avons voulu faire de cette
opération une opération gratuite ouvert
au plus grand nombre de réunionnais
parce que en fin d'année on a envie
d'ouvrir son coeur on a envie de
partager de belles choses de faire
rayonner des étoiles dans la tête de
tout le monde pas seulement des
tout-petits et je crois qu on le réussit
bien parce que c'est une opération qui
est aujourd'hui plébiscité par
l'ensemble des rayonnements
[Musique]
m